I feel very comfortable being in this
city working in Freiburg and live in the
file I like it sighs sometimes I need to
do something on a weekend I just take my
bike and come to the Institute my name
is Javed mala I'm 34 years old I come
from Iran and I'm a physical mythologist
I work at the Institute of our n'mah
steal technology of Freiburg University
of mining and technology still is the
second widely used matter on earth just
after second to complete but the thing
is that the steel has various
applications and old top date people
study the skills for years but then I
realize that there are very new types of
steel we can just manipulate we can just
change the microstructure to to get
better properties my current activities
focuses on stainless steels which are
steals which have a high corrosion or
rusting resistance if you got this
normally these non magnetic seals have a
lot of nickel in them and nickel is an
expensive following elements we would
like to try to replace nickel with
cheaper elements is part of the small
size of university the quality of
research in my opinion is very high
because we got access to the advanced
equipment many of them are available on
campus it's just a university with
around 4,000 students and it has two of
these collaborative research center
funded by German Research Foundation and
one of the leaders of one of the sub
projects the purpose is to combine still
weird ceramic so that we get composite
materials at the moment is just more
about research but it could in the
future also have applications including
in the car industry I'm very happy to be
in a university with such a tradition
it's almost 250 years old and it's in
many widely known researchers
one of the examples is Alexander von
Humboldt who visited bribery who took
some lectures to elements of the
periodic table of elements were actually
discovered by researchers from Freiburg
indium and germanium where those two
elements Freiburg and the surrounding
areas have seen mining activities for
over 800 years because of the large
number of silver mines around Freiburg
it is known as a silver town in the old
town there is a very nice and
beautifully colored collection of
mineral it also reminds us so the long
way it takes before a mineral or before
our and/or is converted to steal